mit einfachen verpackungs tricks werden
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
tagtäglich von der lebensmittelindustrie
zum kaufen animiert wie das funktioniert
zeigt sebastian liege mit selbst
hergestellten gemüse chips gemüse chips
liegen voll im trend und durch
geschickte verpackung holen wir
hersteller fix ein paar prozent mehr aus
das zeigt ein simpler tüten vergleich
zweimal gemüse check einmal marke und
einmal
[Musik]
beide packungen kosten dasselbe 1 eur 99
und doch gibt es einen erheblichen
unterschied
[Musik]
ganz witzig hier sind 60 grad drin
enthalten
und hier 100 aber fast identisch
ähnliche packungsgröße aber deutlich
weniger inhalt nicht der einzige kniff
mit dem hersteller absahnen ist es so
simpel
sebastian will das testen dazu macht er
seine eigenen gemüse chips nach dem
motto wenig inhalt viel drumherum
ob das klappt die richtige verpackung
mit schilf drin eine schwere tüte in
retro papier optik ein etikett mit edlen
gemüse motiv handschrift design plus
foto vom vermeintlichen erzeuger die
ganze packung verströmt hochwertiges bio
handwerks flair
fertig ist die tüte für den test
[Musik]
100 gramm würden reinpassen sebastian
fühlt natürlich nur 50 gramm hinein
damit die halb volle packung nicht so
schlapp aussieht wenn wehrte er einen
beliebten industrie treckern aufpumpen
mit kohlendioxid das hält auch noch den
inhalt knackig und hier ist meine co2
kanone mit richtig für luft offen
kompressor immer noch geld verdienen
eine halb leere tüte zum vollen preis
das merkt auch kein mensch gerade mal 50
grad drinnen sieht aber auch eine
richtig große portion für gemüse öl und
salz hat sebastian gerade einmal 24 cent
bezahlt
wie die hersteller den endpreis genau
berechnen ist ihr geheimnis aber satte
gewinnspannen sind garantiert und gemüse
chips sind kein einzelfall bei jeder
form von flocken und knuspert kam hat
die industrie leichtes spiel
zum beweis röntgen wir unterschiedliche
verpackungen beispiel cornflakes die
billigen von penny sind immerhin zu gut
80 prozent gefüllt
das teure marken produkt von kellogg's
dagegen nur zu rund zwei dritteln auch
bei kartoffelchips ist viel luft in der
verpackung und wieder fällt auf im
markenprodukt sind weniger chips als in
der neuen variante trendy ist euer
beispiel fanny bei dem nostalgischen
stampfkartoffeln ist der füllstand nur
etwa halb so hoch wie beim schlichten
kartoffelbrei der preis für die größte
mobile packung geht an studentenfutter
die tüte ist nicht mal bis zur mitte
gefüllt
[Musik]
eigentlich sagt der gesetzgeber eine
verpackung darf über den inhaltlich
hinwegtäuschen dass heißt es ist eine
irreführung das ist eine täuschung
die hersteller führen technische gründe
an
die maschinen könnten es nicht besser
wann eine mogelpackung vorliegt ist
gesetzlich übrigens nicht genau geregelt
dafür gibt es tipps die ziemlich
praxisfern klingen hier sagt der
gesetzgeber ich kann ja als verbraucher
dessau tasten
wir finden diese verpackung könnte aber
auch kleiner sein bevor man blind links
auf chipstüten herumdrückt vergleicht
man wohl besser die 100 gramm preise
denn das lohnt sich wie dieses beispiel
zeigt die cornflakes links kosten zwei
euro 49 rechts 99 cent ungefähr gleiche
packungsgröße weniger inhalt so kommt
man bei kellogg's corn flakes mit
reichlich luft im karton auf etwa 65
cent pro 100 gramm reflex der penny
eigenmarke kosten nicht mal ein drittel
gleiches bild beim nächsten beispiel 100
gramm der funny frisch tipps kosten fast
doppelt so viel wie die kartoffel chips
von lidl und das bei gleich großer
verpackung die luftnummer aber ist nur
ein beliebter trick immer mehr
verpackungen locken mit
qualitätsversprechen
dabei bedient sich die industrie eines
psychologisch sehr effektiven kniffs
wahnsinn das gibt es jetzt auf jedem
produkt gibt es überhaupt noch produkte
ohne qualitätsprädikat ohne irgendeine
auslobung ich glaube nicht tatsache fast
überall finden wir siegel und
qualitätsversprechen manche sind auch
wirklich verbindlich das sechseckige
biosiegel oder die rechteckige variante
der eu sind starke siegel mit einem
gesetz dahinter einsatz von pestiziden
und tierschutz sind streng geregelt wenn
es um produkte aus entwicklungsländern
geht hilft das fairtrade-siegel bei der
kaufentscheidung
es wird ebenfalls unabhängig
kontrolliert hier immer was das kenn ich
fairtrade damit der bau auch mal euro
mehr in der tasche behält und nicht nur
die großen konzerne diese reibach machen
es wirklich ein super label aber was ist
mit anderen bekannten gütesiegeln das
dlg siege aber hier haben sie mal schön
von 2015 weiter gedruckt ist die version
denn genau so gut wie damals einmal
verliehen gilt als siegel noch weitere
zwei jahre
und was sagt es aus nicht allzu viel
die industrie testet sich selbst
bewertet vor allem geschmack und aroma
das ergebnis über 80 prozent der
eingereichten produkte werden prämiert
also bei den produkt ziegeln kann der
hersteller siegel auf den markt bringen
wenn er bestimmte kriterien dafür
festlegt was für verbraucher dann
ziemlich schwierig ist nachzuvollziehen
wenn man im supermarkt steht das neue
siegel sieht und dann die kriterien
nicht kennt das heißt die verbraucher
müssen dann im prinzip über das internet
oder über recherche nachvollziehen woher
die kriterien kommen
hilfe bietet die seite siegel klarheit
de oder die narbung siegel app hier kann
man gütesiegel direkt kennen immerhin
eine möglichkeit sich zu informieren
praktisch machtlos ist man bei einer
weiteren verpackungsmaschine einmal noch
schönes ein eigenes label schonend
gepresst aus wertvollen keimen es gleich
wieder ein qualitätsprädikat auf immer
mehr verpackungen immer mehr versprechen
die gut klingen aber nichts bedeuten
müssen
hier ist auch noch was ganz witziges
qualität aus freude am café milliliter
billiger trick
solange solche selbst erfundenen siegel
keine geschützten begriffe enthalten
unterliegen sie keine pflicht für
unabhängige kontrollen klares hersteller
sieht der hersteller macht es drauf um
hier eine qualität entweder
vorzutäuschen oder die qualität ist drin
das kann man immer schwierig beurteilen
aber hier prüft niemand nach ob das
jetzt auch stimmt auch sebastian nägel
braucht für seine selbst kreierte
chipstüte noch ein siegel
dazu legt er kurzerhand selbst das
testkriterium fest nämlich was schmeckt
seinem hund kalle sobald stehen
natürlich nur die eigenen chip langsam
langsam
testsieger kalla gesagt das sind die
besten gemüse chips ein label ohne echte
aussagekraft und doch völlig legal
die masche ist vom gesetz her erlaubt
[Musik]
sebastian will die wirkung der
verpackung testen
dazu führt er seine selbstgemachten
gemüse chips in drei unterschiedliche
typen
zwei davon kennt man aus dem
supermarktregal
die dritte ist die selbst designte mit
dem testsieger nebel drei verschiedene
verpackungen
der inhalt wird überall der gleiche sein
mal sehen die leute sich von den siegeln
irre führen lassen
schmecken die tester unterschiede
obwohl überall derselbe drin
los geht's mit der ersten titel
vermeintlich die biochip von penny
[Musik]
sebastian welt designte chips packung
wirkt sich die premium tüte auf den
geschmack ganz anders die tester
schmecken erste unterschiede die letzte
tüte stammt vom markenprodukt
funny-frisch die packung verspricht
besondere würze schmecken die gleichen
chips deshalb anders kräftigen geschmack
das ist mir ja der breiten geschmack
unglaublich alle probanden schmecken
unterschiede
obwohl überall die gleichen chips drin
sind aber aus welche tüte schmeckt am
besten zieht das testsieger leben
ich würde mir die reifen okay wer meine
persönliche aus wollen also die fand
jets am besten
okay was wir jetzt ein favorit am besten
fand ich die erst mit mir besser als
regen wir
ich glaube die haben hier am besten
geschmeckt wenn ich kaufe ja dieses du
wirst sie diese kaufen hat für mich
alles bestimmt okay von der konsistenz
ja so war nicht zu knacken nicht wie
drucken sowie wird um war super ist
überall das gleiche drin
nein und wie steht der testsieger weißt
du wer der test da war man nun
tatsächlich der trick funktioniert die
tester haben sich von der aufgemotzten
packung in die irre führen lassen
ausnahmslos alle schmeckten unterschiede
wo gar keine waren die meisten hätten
sich für sebastians trick verpackung mit
wertlos siegel und leeren versprechen
entschieden
für experten kein zufall
sigl und slogans wirken sogar über das
eigentliche versprechen hinaus so etwas
nennt man über strahlungs effekt
kundenschreiben einem produkt auch
qualitäten zu die gar nicht versprochen
wurden
da finden wir eben diesen über
strahlungs effekt man kann
beispielsweise zeigen dass wenn ich
kartoffelchips habe das wenig
schokoladenriegel habe die
beispielsweise bio label tragen
gütesiegel tragen dass die auch als
weniger gesundheitsschädlich
wahrgenommen werden obwohl natürlich die
inhaltsstoffe die in einen bio produkt
sind einem schokoriegel oder
kartoffelchips die gleichen sind sie
sind nur unter anderen bedingungen
hergestellt worden
das nutzen die firmen aus sie drucken
auf ihre produkte siegel oder sie
gelartige buttons wo sie nur können und
wir werden regelrecht zum kauf verleiten
was also können wir tun bei der
aktuellen situation so wie wir sie haben
was diese gesundheitsbezogenen aussagen
angeht wäre fast die empfehlung die
einfach erstmal zu ignorieren und dann
doch in die zutatenliste zu gehen in die
nährwertkennzeichnung zu gehen sich das
anzuschauen heißt der blick auf die
zutaten gibt nach wie vor mehr
aufschluss über das produkt als die
meisten siegen
[Musik]
lasst ihr euch von den verpackungs
tricks in die irre führen
und welchen qualitätssiegeln vertraut
ihr wirklich sagt es uns in den
kommentaren
und wo ist die besten lebensmittel gibt
und was wirklich drin steckt zeigen wir
euch auf unserem kanal zdf besser